- I don't feel like I'm
taking crazy pills anymore.
The 11th Circuit has
ruled against Donald Trump
in the Mar-a-Lago
classified documents case,
and it is a beat down.
Now, because today is
a day that ends in Y,
that means this channel is here to explain
what all of this means,
because try as I might
to get away from Trump,
he just keeps inserting himself
into the most interesting
legal cases in the country.
So, strap in for an explanation
for why Judge Cannon might have ruled
in Trump's favor initially.
The Court of Appeals is not
going to suffer any fools.
So, let's start with a recap
of what brought us to this point.
On September 5th, 2022,
Judge Aileen Cannon,
who was controversially
confirmed to the bench
after Trump was defeated for reelection,
authorized the appointment
of a special master
to conduct an independent
review of some 11,000 documents
and some 1,800 items that
were seized from Mar-a-Lago
pursuant to a search warrant.
Judge Cannon also took
the extraordinary step
of temporarily enjoining the government
from reviewing and using
the seized materials
for investigative purposes,
pending completion of the
special master's review
or further order of the court.
In other words, Judge Cannon's ruling
forced the DOJ to halt
its criminal investigation
of Donald Trump until the special
master completed his work.
Though she did allow
the Office of the Director
of National Intelligence,
the ODNI, to continue
its classification review
and/or intelligence
assessment of those documents.
Now, the DOJ swiftly appealed
Judge Cannon's ruling
to the 11th Circuit.
That is the Court of Appeals
that oversees Judge Cannon.
But it also separately
petitioned Judge Cannon
for a partial stay of her ruling.
It went back to her to
ask her to partially stay
part of the things that she had ordered.
Now, in that motion,
the DOJ argued that
Judge Cannon's injunction
risked irreparable harm
to national security
by interfering with the
government's criminal investigation
and forcing disclosure of
these classified documents
to a special master.
And the DOJ further argued
that it's simply not possible
to separate the DOJ and the
FBI's criminal investigation,
which was blocked,
from the intelligence
community's assessment,
which was allowed to continue.
As a result, the DOJ argued
that the order had created
confusion in the executive branch
and disrupted intelligence
agencies' ability
to assess any damage to national security.
For relief, the DOJ
requested a partial stay
of Judge Cannon's order
that would allow the FBI
to use the 103 documents
marked as classified for
further criminal investigation
and not require the disclosure
to the special master.
And on September 15th,
Judge Cannon rejected the DOJ's motion,
and in her ruling,
Judge Cannon refused to accept
the government's argument
that Trump could never
assert any privilege
or property interest on the documents
with classified markings.
Those are property of the government.
Judge Cannon also refused to accept
the government's contention
that the documents marked as classified
are actually classified,
or contain extremely sensitive information
that could harm national
security if disclosed.
Judge Cannon then formally
appointed Judge Raymond Dearie
to lead an independent review
of the seized materials.
Then, after Trump and the
DOJ submitted two names
to be appointed as special master,
Judge Cannon agreed to
appoint Judge Raymond Dearie,
who was one of Trump's picks,
to lead an independent review
of the seized material.
She further directed Judge
Dearie to prioritize review
of the roughly 100 documents
with classification markings,
with a goal of completing the
review of all the documents
by November 30th, 2022.
Now, we'll talk about this later,
but Trump may live to regret
this whole special master gambit,
and especially regret agreeing to Dearie
as the special master.
But the DOJ then appealed the
denial of the partial stay
to the 11th Circuit Court of Appeals.
So, let's talk about
this particular decision
from the 11th Circuit.
Now, legal experts attacked
Judge Cannon's ruling en masse
as legally unsound and
ripe for being overturned.
However, there was some
concern that the 11th Circuit
would let Judge Cannon's injunction stand.
After all, the 11th Circuit
is a relatively conservative
court of appeals,
with Trump having nominated
six of the 11 active judges
on the circuit.
And recent history shows
how some Trump appointees,
like Judge Cannon herself,
have been quite unpredictable
in their particular rulings.
But in a unanimous opinion
issued on September 21st,
the 11th Circuit Court of Appeals
granted the government's
motion for a partial stay.
In a strongly-worded 29-page decision,
the three-judge panel,
made up of two Trump appointees
and one Obama appointee,
ruled that Judge Cannon
likely erred as matter of law
by exercising jurisdiction
to "enjoin the United States's
use of classified records
"in its criminal investigation
"and to require the United States
"to submit marked classified documents
"to a special master for review."
Now, this decision was per curiam,
meaning that all three judges
equally supported the opinion.
And as a result, the Justice Department
was no longer prohibited
from investigating the documents
marked with classified
markings that were seized
nor would it be required
to share those materials
to the special master for
his independent review.
But it's not just that the
11th Circuit granted the DOJ
its requested relief.
What's so notable about this opinion
is how it reads like a
complete repudiation,
both the legal reasoning
behind Judge Cannon's order
and some of Trump's more
specious factual claims.
Now, in deciding whether to
grant the stay pending appeal,
the Court of Appeals
evaluated four factors
articulated by the Supreme Court
in the Nken versus Holder case.
First, whether the stay applicant
has made a strong showing
that he is likely to
succeed on the merits.
Two, whether the applicant
will be irreparably injured
absent a stay.
Three, whether issuance of the stay
will substantially injure
the other party's interest
in the proceedings.
And four, whether the
public interest lies.
And on every single point,
the 11th Circuit sided with the DOJ
to find that the stay pending
the appeal was justified.
Now, for the first factor,
the DOJ demonstrated it was
likely to succeed on the merits
of its claim under the Richey analysis.
Now, when a person seeks
return of seized property
in pre-indictment cases,
those actions are governed
by equitable principles,
whether viewed as based on
Federal Rule of Criminal Procedure 41(g)
or the general equitable
jurisdiction of federal courts.
That's according to the Richey case.
And under the Richey case,
when evaluating whether to
intervene pre-indictment,
courts assess four factors
pursuant to Richey,
which we talked about in our prior video.
One, whether the government
displayed a callous disregard
for constitutional rights in
seizing the items at issue.
Two, whether the plaintiff
has an individual interest in
and need for the material
whose return he seeks.
Three, whether the plaintiff
would be irreparably injured
by denial of the return of property.
And four, whether the plaintiff
has an adequate remedy
at law for the redress of his grievance.
Now, under all four of the Richey factors,
the Court of Appeal found that
the DOJ was likely to succeed
on the merits of its claim.
Namely, that Judge Cannon's order
blocking the criminal investigation
and turning over classified
records to the special master
was an abusive discretion
that was made in error.
Now, the panel noted that
even Judge Cannon found
no callous disregard for
Trump's constitutional rights
and neither party contested this finding.
And the Court of Appeals pointed out
that this alone should have been enough
to end the district court's inquiry.
"The absence of this indispensable factor
"in the Richey analysis is
reason enough to conclude
:that the district court
abused its discretion
"in exercising equitable
jurisdiction here."
Now, it's basically judicial lawyer speak
for telling Judge Cannon politely
that her entire analysis was
flawed from the very beginning.
Now, this is a factor-based test,
but basically the court
can almost never exercise
its equitable jurisdiction
without the presence of callous disregard
for constitutional rights.
And in this case, it wasn't even close.
But for the sake of
doing a complete takedown
of Judge Cannon's opinion, the
Court of Appeals continued.
Now, for example, while Judge
Cannon was open to Trump
having a potential property interest
in classified materials,
the 11th Circuit was skeptical
that Trump had any property
interest in them at all.
"For our part, we cannot
discern why Plaintiff
"would have an individual interest in
"or need for any of the
one-hundred documents
"with classified markings."
Discussing the law of classification,
the court explained that access
to classified information
is only allowed if a person
has a need to know the information
or if the current administration
has waived this requirement.
But as the Court of Appeals noted,
Trump hadn't provided any evidence
that either of these things had happened.
"Plaintiff has not even attempted to show
"that he has a need to
know the information
"contained in the classified documents.
"Nor has he established that
the current administration
"has waived the requirement
for these documents."
"And even if he had,
that, in and of itself,
"would not explain why Plaintiff
has an individual interest
"in the classified documents."
The Court of Appeals
called Trump's suggestion
that he declassified these
documents a red herring
because declassification
would have zero effect
on the character of the
document and would not explain
why he has a personal interest in them.
As many legal experts have noted,
Trump has repeatedly
claimed on social media
and in interviews that he
declassified the documents.
But Trump specifically
avoided making these claims
in a judicial setting supported by,
what's the word?
Evidence, that's it.
No evidence whatsoever.
And the Court of Appeals noticed.
"The record contains no evidence
"that any of these
records were declassified.
"And before the special master,
"Plaintiff resisted providing any evidence
"that he had declassified
any of these documents."
Now, what the Court of
Appeals was referring to
was just days earlier,
Trump's lawyers specifically refused
the special master's
request to provide evidence
that these documents were declassified,
claiming that doing so would force Trump
to "disclose a defense to the merits
"of any subsequent indictment."
And in fact, they're absolutely right,
and it would be entirely prejudicial
to disclose a defense to an indictment.
But those are post-indictment arguments,
not pre-indictment arguments,
like what we're dealing with right here.
But they should probably talk
to their client about that
because he keeps going
on TV and locking himself
into specific defenses
that actually are not
particularly good defenses at all.
Go figure.
But at any rate, regarding
the third Richey factor
of irreparable harm to Trump,
Judge Cannon had argued that
he could be potentially harmed
if the classified documents
were not returned, based on:
one, improper disclosure
of sensitive information
to the public;
two, the United States retention
and use of privileged materials;
and three, the stigma associated
with future prosecution.
But the Court of Appeals
explained in meticulous detail
why all of those
arguments were 100% wrong.
For starters, the whole
reason the government
was investigating the documents
was to limit unauthorized disclosure,
and Trump has not asserted
attorney-client privilege
over the classified documents
so there can't be a harm to
his privilege there either.
And as to the final Richey factor,
which asked whether the
plaintiff has an adequate remedy
at law for the redress of his grievance,
well, the court noted that
Trump has a remedy at law.
He simply has chosen not to invoke it.
The court explained that Trump could file
a Rule 41(g) motion to
get the documents back,
but he hasn't.
But even if he did,
Trump "has not identified any reason
"that he is entitled to those documents."
So, based on the four-factor Richey test,
the DOJ demonstrated it was
likely to succeed on the merits.
But returning to the Nken analysis,
the Court of Appeals held
that the United States would
suffer irreparable harm
if Judge Cannon's injunction
was not partially stayed.
Finding that the government's
national security review
is inextricably intertwined
with its criminal investigation,
the 11th Circuit explained that
allowing the order to stand
would create a chilling
effect on national security.
Basically, it's not
good for the government
when it cannot control
extremely classified documents.
And to illustrate this,
the court noted that officials who oversee
both national security and
criminal investigations
into classified information
might be forced to choose
between doing their jobs
and facing contempt charges.
And with respect to the third Nken factor,
the DOJ demonstrated irreparable harm
while Trump had not
demonstrated irreparable harm.
The court reiterated
that Trump does not have
a possessory interest
in the documents at issue,
so he does not suffer a cognizable harm
if the United States reviews the documents
he neither owns nor has
a personal interest in.
Nor, the court affirmed,
is being criminally investigated itself
a substantial injury to justify a stay.
"Bearing the discomfiture and
cost of prosecution for crime
"even by an innocent person
"is one of the painful
obligations of citizenship."
That is, of course,
according to the famous
Supreme Court case of
Cobbledick versus United States.
And finally, regarding the
public interest factor,
the court noted that
the classified documents
contain information that
"the unauthorized disclosure of
"which reasonably could
be expected to cause
"exceptionally grave damage
to the national security."
The public naturally has
an interest in ensuring
this does not happen.
However, a national security assessment
can only be done if the
government is allowed
to review these documents,
which under the current
injunction couldn't have happened.
And having found the balance of equities
overwhelmingly favored the DOJ,
the Court of Appeals granted
the motion for partial stay
of Judge Cannon's order
pending the entire appeal.
Now, essentially, the Court
of Appeals eviscerated
Cannon's order regarding
the classified documents
and all of its underlying logic.
But here, the DOJ's
appeal was very narrow.
Probably for strategic reasons,
the DOJ only appealed the order
regarding classified documents.
That basically narrowed the
focus of the Court of Appeals
on the classified documents
issue to ignore everything else.
But the upshot, though,
is that the rest of the
special master order remains,
which for reasons I'll
explain in just a moment,
is kind of hilarious at this point.
But let's talk about what happened next
with Judge Cannon and the special master.
Judge Cannon responded to the
partial stay the following day
by modifying her order
appointing the special master.
Judge Cannon revised her original order
by excluding the 100-odd
documents with classified markings
from the special master's review,
deleting the requirement
that the special master
submit interim reports and
recommendations to the court
throughout its review,
and striking a provision
requiring classified documents
under review to be made
available for Trump's counsel
for inspection under the
special master's supervision.
And this might be the 11th
Circuit's last word on this issue
and it may never get to the Supreme Court
because according to many
respected legal analysts,
like Steve Vladeck at
the University of Texas,
Trump can't ask the entire 11th Circuit
to rehear the appeal on bunk
because the judge has
basically removed anything
that was objectionable.
Same thing goes for the Supreme Court.
And that same day, Special
Master Raymond Dearie
released a case management plan
for his review of the
Mar-a-Lago documents.
Now, in this plan, he
asked Trump's legal team
to state by September 30th
whether they believed
any of the seized items
were incorrectly described
by the Justice Department's
11-page inventory list.
And the judge also
asked Trump's legal team
to state whether they claim
any of the items on the inventory list
were not in fact taken from the premises.
Trump has repeatedly
claimed on social media
and in interviews that
the FBI planted evidence
when they searched Mar-a-Lago.
Claims that his lawyers have
specifically not made in court,
probably because it requires evidence
and subjects you to sanctions.
Instead, Trump's legal team
asserts that they can't affirm
that the government's
inventory is accurate
without first reviewing
the seized materials.
But as to Trump's out-of-court
claims of planted evidence,
Judge Dearie is asking his
legal team to, in legal speak,
put up or shut up.
And because Dearie is not putting up
with some of the same
nonsense that Cannon did,
it seems like Trump may come to regret
pushing for this
particular special master.
The impact of the 11th
Circuit's ruling was immediate
and not limited to Trump's case.
The same day Judge Cannon
modified her order,
a Trump-appointed federal judge
cited the 11th Circuit's ruling
to deny Mike MyPillow Lindell's motion
for the return of his
cell phone by the FBI.
Mike Lindell, who you probably know,
has propagated increasingly
bizarre conspiracy theories
about how the 2020 election was stolen
and that he can get Donald
Trump reinstated as president,
is being investigated
by federal authorities
in connection with the breach
of a Colorado county's voting system.
His phone was seized at
a Hardee's drive-through,
which isn't legally relevant.
It's just, I think, very, very funny.
And bizarrely, hours after
the Court of Appeals ruling,
Trump went on Sean Hannity
to vent about the
variety of legal troubles
that he's facing,
like the New York Attorney General's
civil fraud action against Trump
and three of his adult
middle-aged children
that was announced earlier in the day.
- I actually thought that
they would never bring a case
and she brought it.
- And when the conversation turned
to the classified documents,
Trump once again claimed he
had declassified the documents.
Trump claimed declassification procedures
were essentially optional.
telling Sean Hannity that as president,
he had the power of
declassification with his mind.
- If you're the president
of the United States,
you can declassify just by
saying it's declassified,
even by thinking about it.
- And legal experts weighed in
and it should come as no surprise that no,
the declassification
processes are not optional
and presidents cannot
declassify them with their mind.
And in addition to producing
a new psychic presidential
power to Hannity's audience,
Trump also speculated
the FBI seized documents
from Mar-a-Lago because they were looking
for Hillary Clinton's deleted emails.
- Were they looking for
the Hillary Clinton emails
that were deleted, but
they are around someplace?
- Yeah, I also don't know
how that makes any sense whatsoever.
But it's not hopeless
for all those lawyers
making terrible, terrible arguments
and the former president.
They can quickly get their brains back
to functioning correctly
with a logic or math course
from today's sponsor, Brilliant.
Brilliant is an online
learning platform for STEM
that replaces lecture videos
with hands-on, interactive lessons.
Brilliant is for curious learners,
both young and old,
inexperienced and professionals,
students and those who are
not studying anything anymore.
You can quickly learn
to ace your high school
or college math course,
or just learn stuff that
you always wanted to learn.
One of my favorite courses
is all about logic,
something we haven't seen a whole lot of
coming out of Florida these days.
But Brilliant's logic courses
cover liar and truth teller riddles,
logical fallacies, machine logic,
and even some strategic game theory.
Logic is a crucial skill
that lawyers need every day.
Well, at least most lawyers.
But Brilliant's statistics
and finance classes
are equally good.
You will love them as well.
Brilliant lets you learn by doing
rather than just listening
to hours of boring lectures.
Learning through doing
is scientifically proven
to be the most effective
way to master any new skill.
The courses have storytelling,
interactive challenges,
and problems to solve.
So, you can sign up and
start learning for free today
by clicking on the link
that's on screen right now.
The first 200 people to sign up
will get 20% off their
annual subscription.
So, by clicking on the link
that's on screen right now,
or in the description,
you'll get 20% off your
subscription to Brilliant.
Plus, clicking that link
really helps out this channel.
And after that,
click on this playlist over
here for more LegalEagle
or I'll see you in court.